all right we got a call that came in
right here uh from one of these Gator
babies right here and these these men
have been dealing with prehistoria
and I want to talk to a man who captured
one of them down there in uh Mississippi
over there and they just captured a 800
pound
uh alligator can you imagine that
can you imagine your wife thinks you're
cheating on her
and you show up and you just
your arms you've got lacerations all
over
um yeah let's get to the call uh Joey
Clark I believe is the man Joey
hey what's going on Theo how you doing
man what's up boss I see you got that
Ole Miss shirt on for yourself yes
indeed man if I'm coming on a uh an LSU
boys uh podcast I gotta gotta represent
right we'll call it a truce for a little
while baby how about that man there you
go for about three or four weeks and
it's back on okay deal man I'm turning
into a UT fan too here in uh in
Tennessee
um Joey tell me about this Gator baby
you guys caught that Gator huh yeah man
um this uh went with three of my buddies
out there uh we were in we're outside of
Yazoo City and um oh yeah that's where
um uh Jerry Clowers from Yazoo City
Mississippi that's exactly right that's
exactly right uh went out there in Yazoo
City and we've been to this spot you
know over the years I think this is
probably the
fourth or fifth Gator I've caught with
these guys something like that
um so we've been to that spot several
times and y'all are Gator buddies huh
that's right that's right I've been with
these fellas a few times and and they've
been several years without me as well
um and so you get out there you guys get
out there you're in a what kind of
vessel are you guys in not a submarine
or anything huh no we're in a we're in a
14-foot John Boat yeah boy I know we
brought this thing in the uh oh that's
some Tom Sawyer Water work right there
buddy that's right that's right that
that Gator was about a about a foot
hanging off of that boat while we were
trying to get back in at night and so
what are you hook him on when you are
you aiming for this type of big gate or
are you aiming what are you trying to
catch are you guys looking for flounder
what are you guys trying to catch out
there yeah when you're out there you're
I mean in this area we've we've hooked
up and caught you know several you know
12 12 and a half foot Gators out there
and that's really what we're looking for
you know we don't you know in
Mississippi the cool thing about here is
it's not like Louisiana it's not
commercial they only give out about 900
tags a year so we got drawn in the
lottery so you want to make it count
right you want to make your Gator count
you don't want to come in there with a
little non-foot Gator if you don't have
to but uh you know nothing against that
just we've done that before right so so
we it's probably embarrassing I guess if
four men get out of a boat with a little
baby gator that looks probably yeah I
mean we've uh it's casual looking
we we saw this Gator uh just as we were
putting in right before dark and we had
no idea it was this big so we we hopped
in the boat went out there and um you
know we must have passed 20 to 25 30
Gators on the way out there and they all
look great and it's just a swamp full of
alligators out there but and how do you
can you tell like because the eyes are
usually poking out of the water can you
tell how big a gator is even just by its
eyes poking out you can tell even when
you get you know you're far away from
one you can tell if he's undersized and
something you don't want to fool with
yeah but uh you know you're out there at
night it's it's pitch black there's they
got a pump Sunshine out there to that
part of the part of the state and you
know you're out there in that in that
stuff and you got a q beam and uh you're
just trying to light those eyes up and
and go from there and does the beam
shock the gator at all does it kind of
get like a um like a does it does it
have that deer and headlights effect on
a Gator or what is that like it's not
too much gonna shock him when he's when
he fills the vibrations in the water of
your of your boat and your trolling
motor and all that that's what's going
to make him kind of kind of duck and
start trying to get away from you and
and you know he held his breath it
seemed like 30 to 45 minutes at a time a
couple times and oh wow we just had to
keep on searching him and um you know we
hooked up to him the first time and what
do you mean are you hooking him on a
spinner bait what do you got I mean what
do you even put out there yep so it's
just a treble hook what are you guys
using are you guys using chicken livers
like what do you use it what's the bait
no there's no bait whatsoever oh there's
no no no bait whatsoever you're out
there you know you've got to see this
Gator and then you've got to be talented
enough to be able to throw a uh just to
throw that treble hook throw that line
right where you want to do it okay so
you're not so so there's no bait in
there there's you're not trying to get
them to get something like a fish or it
is more you are just trying to get the
hook into his body that's right that's
right trying to get the hook in his body
and you know eventually we kept on
trying to hit him with one one line at a
time and we did that but he kept
breaking off and what these Gators do
um we must have we probably hooked up on
him seven or eight times I guess and he
kept on you know shaking that that
treble hook out of him but what they're
trying to do is go under logs and things
like that and and shake that that hook
out of them and then they're free
um and so that's that's kind of what the
the gist is there and do they seem nasty
like did this Gator seem like a nasty
guy or what did he say like can you get
any a semblance of what their
personality is like did he seem like a
nasty guy yeah man he was uh he wouldn't
meet a skater we've ever run across
we've run across some meaner ones but he
was very territorial you know he did the
the weird thing is we've hooked up on
some good sized Gators in the past and
you know you hook them once or twice and
now they kind of get the gist of what's
going on you're trying to kill him and
they disappear you'll never see him
again but this Gator he wouldn't do that
uh he was there in that area you know
he's just uh he's probably a hoarder
have you seen that show like my 700
pound life or something that because
that those people don't not you know
they're usually locked in their house
with magazine you know they have like
stacks of magazines and everything
that's right
over there yeah he's in his spot and
he's not trying to get out of there he's
uh he's doing his thing and uh like I
say he never left he never left the 200
yard radius force and that's just crazy
to me that that it happened like that
because we hooked into it for the first
time about 9 30 at night and we didn't
have that thing in the boat until 3 30
in the morning my God and so you hook
him you start getting him and now how
close is the boat as are you just right
next to him
yeah you are so you know we I'd say when
you hook up on him initially you know
you're probably within 15 feet of the
Gator probably so yeah I wouldn't be
there buddy yeah I'd call a damn Uber
buddy I would not be right there I'll be
glad to send you a couple of little
videos we took on the boat so you can
kind of see for yourself on this uh if
that'd be something that would help kind
of put it together for you we'd love
that we'll play some of those side by
side while we're talking about it okay
so you get them you you have how many
hooks do you eventually get into the
gator finally at the end we did get a
second hook in and we had one the first
hook we caught which is not where you
want to catch him would be uh back at
the tail and that's that's where my
buddy Don he blind cast out over him
hooked him in the tail we fought him for
about another 30 minutes we could get a
second hook in him damn uh you know and
so kind of my job with all this is when
I'm in the boat you know we've got a
snare or whatever and my job is once
he's come up what do you mean a snare
yeah so it's like a um
no not a drum it's uh it's kind of like
um I I caught almost like a noose right
I mean it's you you've got a rope on the
end of it you slip it over his head and
then when you do it I just pull that
rope as hard as I can and basically try
to sit down on the bottom of the boat
until uh so there's some damn BDSM
it sounds like yes indeed yes indeed wow
it's so it's crazy if you wind up and
get him at 14 feet uh three inches so it
as of today we've got still got 24 hours
left in the state of Mississippi for
gator hunting season but as of today
it's the state record wow and how much
weight was it
802.5 pounds damn boy and that missed
that missed the state record by 20
pounds so that just tells you how big
they are down here oh so it didn't even
make the weight record but it made the
length record that's right that's
exactly right
that's incredible man it is it is so
once you have both of those hooks how
are you elevating it out of the water
what's like how does your boat not
capsize yeah so you know what he's doing
when he's down there underwater he's
he's you know he's fighting and he's
down there and he's been down there at
the you know at this point you know over
that seven hour period he had been in
that water uh you know underwater the
majority of that time but they got to
come up for air right they gotta they at
some point they can't stay underwater
forever they got to come up so when they
do you got to think about it as you're
you know these guys with the two lines
are pulling him closer and closer to the
boat
um as they continue to fight him and he
continues to come up for air a little
bit more frequently towards the end and
that's you know when it gets close
enough to the boat within you know I'd
say two or three feet if you can and
that's when you want to put that that
snare around him and and hook him from
there and kind of finish the deal off
and do you choke him out does somebody
get on him how do you finish him man I'm
trying like hell to choke him out I'm
like I'm just holding him as tight as I
can until somebody can shoot him oh
shoot him skater yeah yeah you got to
shoot him yeah
that's right that's a damn robbery bro
it is it's a it's a mugging for sure it
is
no no no no you got to put that bad boy
last thing you want to do is tow him in
and and then you lose him or something
yeah because once if he were to break
off a rope or something he's at the
bottom of the river you're not getting
him back you know and when he went after
he right when he dies do y'all hug or
what are people like is there a
celebration what is that moment like man
it's just a sense of relief you've been
out there with him all night long and
the last thing you want to do is let him
off the hook look we had been out there
for so long we were all just getting
tired and worn out we've been working
all day all four of us just you know
doing our thing and nobody wanted to
give up and we all thought about it but
at the end of the night you know my
buddy Tanner the entire time uh he was
like we're not letting the skater go
we're just not going to do it so he was
he was hell-bent on getting this gator
in the boat oh every Tanner I know will
get hell-bent they get hell-bent on all
kind of you put a couple beers in
them were you guys having a couple beers
no there's no drinking out there there's
no drinking it's a little bit too unsafe
or that yeah we try to be as legal as we
could with getting this gator in and out
and thank God we did because now you
know I mean immediately reported out
obviously the state wildlife department
gets called they got to come measure it
and confirm it and but no no party and
the partying was after I guess the you
know over the over the last 10 days just
trying to uh let all this stuff sink in
man it's it's growing and blown up
beyond our wildest expectations man man
that's exciting brother yeah and do you
all name him or anything is there any uh
uh is there anything like that do you
all barium what's the what happens is
there anything that happen like that you
know so we don't I don't we didn't name
them if we would have I wish you kind of
brought something up maybe we should do
that
um but the uh with the meat we've
donated the meat to a uh to an
organization there in Yazoo City they
kind of just you know divvy that meat
out
um to you know
things like that yeah it came out to
like 380 pounds of meat so it was a ton
of meat on that
they had an orphanage by us and they
would always whenever people would cut
uh that a lot of donated meat would go
over there and sometimes I had a buddy
that was over there and we'd go over
there and eat and they'd always be
eating Gator up in that it's kind
of wild to think oh it's crazy you go in
there and you see 20 freaking orphans
bro no I don't yummy yumming down on
some Gator it's just like man get him
some gator sausage and then let them
have a weekend you know oh yeah if they
don't have parents dude get them some
decent meat that's what I think
everybody deserves something exactly but
yeah man it's uh that that was you know
kind of the gist of the of the Gator
itself and um you know I guess with this
hide we're gonna get some leather boots
made we're gonna be looking sharp come
uh come Christmas time I guess we'll see
what's up but uh that's the plan well
praise brother thank you so much for
just jumping on and and filling Us in on
some information it's really fascinating
and congratulations on the state record
man that's amazing well I appreciate it
man it's very nice talking to you and uh
like I said it's been a wild ride and um
I'll send you those videos so you can
check that out and kind of see put this
into perspective what it's like out
there in the pitch black at night yeah
brother please do also just great to
talk to somebody
um from over there near Yazoo City
Mississippi the home of Jerry Clower are
my favorite comedian so uh thank you so
much Joey Clark we appreciate you
brother thank you man nice talking to
you all right cheers buddy have a good
one take care